[Music]
well good morning everyone
um I'd like to share my perspective with
you on climate and sustainability and
the issues that we have and I love the
theme of action in the future and
looking out for next Generations and
from you know would we imagine our
future for children is something happy
prosperous clean Skies soil grass
everything is wonderful unfortunately
the reality is right now what we're
already seeing the future may not be as
happy and prosperous as we would imagine
too for our grandchildren and children
and these are actual pictures from the
recent events around the globe that we
had from tornadoes fires devastations
and the Common Thread between all of
these advances unfortunately is the
climate change and this is something
that most of you if not all of you
pretty aware that it's a big
contributing factor to these Global
events
so what causing Global change is pretty
obvious to some maybe not to others but
it's essentially since Industrial
Revolution we've emitted a lot of CO2 in
the atmosphere which is carbon dioxide
it's a greenhouse gas that traps the
Heat and our planet gets warmer and over
the last
hundreds of thousands of years we had
never seen or measured these levels of
CO2 in an atmosphere that ever been
before
and so the problem with that trapped
heat is our surface temperatures are
rising and as the surface temperatures
are rising it changes our environment it
changes our atmosphere and actually our
environment is it's a very thin layer
it's so delicate and once we destabilize
that environment it creates a lot of
Ripple effects that's why we see changes
in weather but over the long period of
time which we see how our climates is
changing and not just the temperature
surface temperature but effects it's the
oceans land
um it's the it's changes the weather
patterns and how severe those sweater
patterns are
so the the higher and the the further we
see the increase the more severe the
events we will have and the number of
frequency of those indents
unfortunately our United States
Department of Defense secretary stated
that climate change presents an
existential threat for us and when you
hear from people like that we need to
take it seriously
um the we've heard the speakers the
importance of biodiversity and the
um just even the the life in our animals
and oceans is going to be significantly
affected as the temperatures rise
because we cannot adjust and adopt to
changes that took centuries Millennials
for us to develop and to be where we are
unfortunately we keep producing the CO2
we emit a lot of CO2 in the atmosphere
and some Industries where we're supposed
to decarbonize have reduction we
actually see increase in emission some
of it partly because of the growth some
of these industries are continue to grow
so as you grow the industry even if you
have some decarbonization initiatives
it's not enough
so the the bigger problem with that
you've seen probably some of the
sustainable development goals by United
Nations what they do is they they
provide the overall overarching theme of
what can we do to create that better
future for our next Generations
unfortunately with the climate change
all all of these implementation of all
of these sustainable development goals
are going to be harder
when you have more droughts floodings
hurricanes it's going to be harder to
deliver the resources food especially to
those regions who need it the most
the bigger challenge of it the climate
change problem and emission problem is
so big and is so segmented that there's
no one solution or one industry that we
can tackle to say okay well we solve the
energy problem that's it we can we we're
good
no there's a lot of other contributors
that produce CO2 from buildings
agriculture uh any obviously any type of
raw material extraction from the core of
the Earth all of these processes they
emit CO2 so regardless of what industry
you're in where you work you're
contributing to the climate change so
this is something for us to be aware of
and thinking well I work for a SAS
company I may not we might not have a
big impact but your data centers use
energy and what kind of energies they
use and so on and so on so every
industry whatever we look there's
different rates but it's every everyone
is contributing to the global sort of
accumulation of the CO2
the recent United Nations conference
that was mentioned before too on the cop
26 they weren't very happy about our
decarbonization rates of where we are
there's a lot of pledges there's some
implementations but what we're seeing
right now is not enough
1.5 degrees increase in surface
temperature it's they said sort of like
the limit before we start seeing
a very significant increase in intensity
and severity of events and some of those
events will be irreversible for
millennia
it takes a really really long time to
stabilize our planet
so with that sad reality the most recent
projection projections show that we're
more likely based on what we're doing
right now even with the decarbonization
we're more likely to see the increase of
2.5 degrees Celsius and that's with the
pledges with commitments with the
activities that we're already doing so
if we do if we will do all that what we
promise to do
will still more likely to see 2.5 and
that's not the best case scenario of
what we can do unfortunately the
temperatures might rise even further
than that
just think about what what it will
create in our planet what kind of
societies we will be and we will see
when there's a lack of resources
the resources become scarce when there's
the mass migrations and that can lead to
a lot of other consequences and that's
why Department of Defense looking at it
as a possible existential threat to our
civilization
the other part of the challenge so in
addition to decarbonizing we still have
to remove
at least one billion ton of CO2 and
those projections were before 2025 so
more likely than I will not do that the
best technologies that we have right now
can remove about forty thousand of tons
per year
so we are nowhere at scale and we
currently do not have technologies that
can bring us to that threshold
so that presents a very big challenges
for us we have to do something that
we've never done before absolutely
outside of our comfort zone just beyond
Transformations beyond what we can
imagine in order for us to save and
protect the future for our next
Generations and not just in
grandchildren these are going to be
thousands of years before the planet can
get stabilized
we need to have such a massive and
dramatic changes that it will involve
all Industries across all different
organizations and there's good things a
lot of organizations that work on
tackling these problems we need to
support these organizations and create
more create new we need to look inside
of our companies and see how can we
create value
switching to Net Zero Technologies
switching to and adopting and bringing
the value to different Net Zero
implementation projects
luckily there's a value in that there's
a demand for it but we need Collective
action and we need change
and that change comes within every one
of us
I believe that individually we will not
be able to bridge that Gap but
collectively we can build that bridge
and we can unite each other
to create that future for our children
and lastly you and chief mentioned that
we can and we must win this battle for
our lives and I wanted to add it's not
just our lives it's our next Generation
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]